Сліди пожежі на стінах, уламки від вибуху на вікнах.
І через рік на будівлі офісу Товариства угорської культури Закарпаття
в Ужгороді помітні наслідки терактів.
В лютому 2018-го цей офіс спочатку підпалили,
а через три тижні підірвали.
Письмово просив, щоб вони посилили охорону цих об’єктів, що було обіцяно.
Я в другий раз дуже здивувався, що не була забезпечена охорона будівлі.
Це відбувалося на тлі тривалого дипломатичного конфлікту
між Києвом та Будапештом, який висловлював свою незгоду
з запровадженням нового закону про освіту.
Угорці вважають, що введення переважно української
мови навчанняв школах діаспори дискримінує їх.
Мовна тема стала причиною антиугорських виступів українських праворадикалів.
Тож, в лютому 2018-го багато хто в Ужгороді припускав,
що саме вони причетні до терактів.
Пізніше з’ясувалося, що підпал будівлі здійснили двоє громадян Польщі.
Вони вже визнали свою вину.
Судовий процес у Кракові ще триває і не виключено,
що організатором є німецький журналіст Мануель Оксенрайтер,
пов’язаний з німецькими правопопулістами.
І, як встановили журналісти німецького каналу ARD,
у справі Оксенрайтера є російський слід.
А от підрив офісу угорців в Ужгороді, за даними українського слідства,
здійснили двоє громадян України - колишні атовці
і слідство поки не відхиляє версію, знову ж таки, "російського сліду".
Через рік угорці Закарпаття схильні прийняти цю версію.
Та з одним але.
Такого поля для діяльності цих спецслужб
і зацікавлених осіб не було б, якби через ЗМІ
й українську політику не було б взагалі такого шуму
навколо закарпатських угорців.
Тут є і в Україні такі політичні сили, які зацікавлені в тому,
щоб представити що Україна в колі ворогів і тут
цілісності України представляє якась мізерна спільнота угорців небезпеку.
Угорців звинувачують у сепаратизмі, подвійному громадянстві
і цьому є підтвердження з консульства Угорщини
в Береговому, де роздають угорські паспорти.
В Закарпатській облдержадміністрації впевнені, що місцеві угорці
не можуть бути загрозою для держави і частково згодні з тим,
що деяким політичним силам в Україні було б,
імовірно, вигідно роздмухувати угорське питання.
Але, як рік тому, так і зараз, переконані в причетності
російських спецслужб до терактів в Ужгороді.
Росія давно хоче показати Європі, що Україна має
таке джерело нестабільності не тільки на Сході,
а і прямо під носом ЄС, що не треба з Україною мати
жодних справ, тому що вона непередбачувана.
Вона не може навести лад не тільки там, але і тут.
Ось це головна мета.
Угорці Закарпаття за останні 5 років нарахували
понад 180 різних атак проти себе, в тому числі, інформаційних.
В українських правоохоронців інші дані - різних злочинів,
спрямованих проти угорців, набагато менше.
З 2014-го зафіксовано десь 20-30 різних проявів агресії від праворадикалів
чи-то актів вандалізму, як от цей зухвалий підпал
меморіалу на Верецькому перевалі.
Це пам’ятник угорському поету та революціонеру Шандору Петефі.
Він теж стає постійно об’єктом нападів різних вандалів,
починаючи ще з 2009 року.
Цей пам’ятник ламали, обливали фарбою.
В більшості випадків правоохоронцям не вдалося встановити
ані виконавців, ані організаторів, ані замовників.
Угорська національна меншина найбільша у Закарпатті.
Це майже 100 тисяч мешканців регіону.
Поряд з угорцями живуть представники ще мінімум 20 національних меншин.
Жодна з них не відчувала на собі подібної агресії
ані з боку зовнішніх сил, ані з боку внутрішніх.
Навіть представників російської меншини,
саме культурного товариства, через військову
агресію Кремля, жодного разу не чіпали.
Ніякого натиску, ми нічого як товариство російської культури
не відчуваємо, ніякого....агресії не відчуваємо.
Польська громада Закарпаття, незважаючи на
нещодавні дипломатичні скандали між Києвом та Варшавою
на тлі історичного минулого, теж жодного разу не відчувала ніяких утисків,
як це, приміром, відбувається в сусідній Львівській області.
Тут теж обурені агресією проти угорців.
Це просто інспірація сепаратистських настроїв, яких тут ніколи не було.
Вони були в певних колах, але це швидше такі політичні ігри,
тому що народ в цьому не зацікавлений.
Ужгородська школа мистецтв.
Тут навчаються діти майже 30 національностей.
Вони вивчають пісні й танці усіх національних меншин Закарпаття.
Для регіону, каже викладачка вокалу, це взагалі
нормальне явище - говорити кількома мовами.
Багато хто знає і угорську, і словацьку, і українську, і російську.
Вже на дитячому рівні вже 3-4 мови можна нарахувати.
Рика Рівіс - угорка за національністю.
Вона зізнається, що після минулорічних терактів
не відчуває себе у безпеці, інколи чує неприємні речі про угорців.
Але вона вважає, що теракти проти угорців не досягли мети -
не посварили угорців з українцями чи-то
з місцевими поляками та росіянами.
Саме через традиційне мирне співіснування
різних народів на Закарпатті.